oh
[Musique]
poste
tient chasma faire le plein bouquet
je comptais
rabat succès bongrain annonce aavoir
sétois
qu'est ce qu'il ya
c'est juste un gars que j'ai livré qui
m'a reconnu le mont frist alaska c'est
pour ça que je fais ça tu est rien au
début mhd livrer des pizzas n'ont donc
forcément ya déjà des gens qui l'ont
reconnu sa touche pas s'emballer coup et
moi je lève pas des pizzas espèce de tox
puis celles qui traitent de tox toi et
n'oublie jamais que c'est qu'ils te fais
manger d'accord jamais c'est pas ça mais
c'est jusque là j'ai une chance avec
l'europe si je continue à des crashs
peuvent et ont encore à n'importe quel
moment si je béton je met tout le monde
dans la merde ma mère ma soeur tout le
monde
faut vraiment que j'arrête de betteraves
sergio
pourquoi tu te plains tout le temps toi
on irait m'a dit là il a bien voulu que
tu enregistres avec ma star pour faire
du buzz chez pas quoi là
après on va faire un disque avec toi
si ça marche bien après tout
m
toi
ce que
ça ma femme de ma vie
minerois de cinq ans c'est sûr ça passe
juste une fiche d'intervention mais tout
est vraiment bâtard 3,3 qu'elle existe
pourquoi trek a aucune mère kim qui font
mais si frau mais juste dix mois le nom
de une seule meuf qui te kiffe
ta mère ta merde qu'il tenait à me wade
américain one way c'est plus fort
qu'elle même qu'il fallait ça fait deux
ans l'ensemble c'était un monsieur
vraiment à camille demandé frein à main
entre ta mère a moins un truc quand j'ai
vu de ta mère groupe amèrement un vieil
ami
si
tu veux faire ça m'arrive si tu veux un
petit fonction du
classement dramé
attendu par la cuisine
n'ont même pas j'ai écrit toute la nuit
mon
jeu par un cadeau
6h45
tu voudras bien réveillé ta soeur dans
une heure ou
[Musique]
hélas lève toi
aller plus au foot l'om mais tirons
tapas du shit à livrer toi bon je te
vends du mémoire est juste un peu porte
à ceux ci donnent en plus tu dis oui
vas-y tu vois
arriver
lève c'est bon je voulais oui voilà
un dicton on parle de toi dis c'est
sérieux bah ouais bah déjà il ya une
planète rap et maintenant tout le monde
écoute le son avec ma star ils disent
qu'on est tout de même dit que tu étais
plus strict que nous
pour les gars j'ai reçu les chiffres on
est à 21 milles en vente physique c'est
bien c'est un peu au dessus de ce que
j'imaginais mais surtout ont fait 60
milles en stream c'est du lourd on est
disque d'or en première semaine
et le morceau qui portent l'album c'est
le fit que tu as fait avec apache
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il est temps
qu'on fasse le point sur ton prochain
clip mois le single force et bogota
faudra le tourner en colombie d'ailleurs
il faudrait l'acteur de la série markov
pour notre écoute et moi
ouais l'acteur de la série narco soit
vrai c'est une super idée ça on va
prendre le temps de préparer sa mais
dans l'immédiat je pense qu'on pourrait
clip et le fit de quoi je parle
comme je te dédie ces morceaux qui en
tête des stream faut donner au public ce
qu'il attend ma star est content de
m'être les céder dans les bras que toi
et moi je m'occupe de l'artiste 6 0 bon
ok je comprends ma star mais bogota
c'est le morceau de plus travailler
l'album c'est plus qualitatif faut
prendre le temps de faire ça bien d'un
autre côté il faut que tu saches que
skyrock commencent à rentrer le fit en
boucle ça c'est vrai que laurent bouneau
adore le morceau il le passe à cinq
rotations par jour et vasières et quand
ça décroche aussi peu je donne à cette
force bon là ça moi je sais vraiment
c'est juste que si l'album est numéro un
des ventes sa grâce à ce morceau donc si
tu clés tu relances le buzz et tu gardes
ta place en tête
après on n'est pas obligé de faire un
gros clip on fait un truc vite fait
simple entre un coup tu me donnes pas
trop de force
et frère pas dévié en profite de cela
il fait le vénère géniteur
jeunesse
le futile à 7 millions d'écoutés les
masters et avoir été sur instant
témoin ce que je viens prendre comme
followers mais non tu penses l'adema
fait nous faisons follow commence à nous
on follow telle personne qui t'a faudra
une grosse personnellement polonais on
est trop dans cette aventure mannequins
et aux tubes chantant moi je tenais à
les ramener nos gars les gars il ya la
meuf d'oméga qui est en train de
m'appeler la
halo
ouais ouais bien sûr
à tout à l'heure attendu comme
des frères on a rendez vous chez oméga
arrête tu m'auras parole oméga
donc pas se serrer les gammas stars
commencent à faire d où elle est belle
quand je peux pas venir mais tu me dis
bribes et que tu ça ok comment ça tu
peux pas venir tout manager
commencera manager sur ces interfaces la
trop grosse et moi je t'aide c'est tout
j'ai mes études mon taf c'est chose
justement vient on y va et on verra
après
gros mois dans ce game je veux pas juste
avec mes couilles j'y vais avec les
tiennent aussi
au top et une veste moi je vais pas long
livre ont vite fait comme
non mais oui tout le monde s'en fout
que ça fait un truc à deux carlins tout
bien tu vends car je crois qu'ils
veulent faire leur choix
on va te
attentes en tant que monde la meuf t'a
dit quoi exactement un an juste dit tu
viens la maison de disques et je crois à
me parler de la suite
au non pour l'esquivé
djamileh mognard il a dit je dois rester
avec vous ouais t'as dis ça parce que
vous n'y arrivez pas tomber
on l'a vu la photo que mclaren a posté
et n'irait mois on veut pas que tu
signes avec des gens qui te carottes tu
vois on fait ça pour te protéger mes
écoutes chef bon moment une personne qui
signe rien qu'est mois l'affairé fit
avec master donc on va voir ces gars là
maison de disques c'était normal et
quand faudra dire un truc admirons faire
nous mêmes donc là vous allez à la
maison dit ce qu'ils voulaient pas dire
moyens
vous le dire vous êtes en train
d'essayer de reculer
n'écoute pas ce que je te dis oui
sergio sergio cantone en famille
cal
et moi
car c'est mon grand
c'est il fait des embrouilles je dois te
faire du sale tu sais ce n'est pas
sérieux on grossit mounir c'est mon
grand jeu la malle envers la personne
c'est très bien comme moi comment ils
s'énervent
pendant ce temps juge parle avec ces
gens jettera touche peu il ya du buzz
pour en profiter ouais
aller
voilà
france
bonjour bonjour
apache c'est ça ouais j'ai accompli ok
ils naissent vous attends je vous
accompagne dans les gros fûts merci
beaucoup
wow j'en avais content des clips des
comme ça
c'est bien tu représentes maple brave je
suis manager d'apache notamment et j'ai
plein d'autres artistes inventent un
beau joe ariwa wicked par exemple
belgique iga craintes sur ge achète en
forêt niño plan and in your way a juste
envoyé dans l'immeuble voulait que je
prévienne un nom notamment préféré
d'étonnant puisque on en embrouille en
plus en ce moment tu vois c'est à dire
je veux rappeler mois
aurait été gardé en plus un
quand je vous disais qu'il était large
et expliquer le choix j'ai vraiment
pensé manager c'est compliqué un peu
l'invite à capter c'est pas comme on
veut c'est façon je vais t'expliquer non
vraiment
ça va oui ni non je te présente apache
qui vient d'enregistrer un phitek mostar
comment va tranquille c'est un honneur
de rencontrer franchement je suis
totalement fan de ce que tu fais merci
free rosso fait plaisir je connais pas
mais je vais écouter ce qu'il fait
signer ça valide ce que c'est bon déjà
tu va sonner chez omega
écoute moi et m'ont appelé donc je suis
là
alors monté la tête c'est une première
rencontre on me rendez vous c'est
toujours important ne serait pas raison
bon annie sa trappe dirais oui
parce vocaux
et
ces moments là on va y aller ouais
entrée
10 ans
bonjour vaches je suis ravi de te
rencontrer
après ça va là
je ne sais pas
je te présente stéphane tishman le
patron du label jangle personnes vont
recevoir
et et clément mas je te laisse nous
présenter faute
why are we lire mon manager que vous
connaissez déjà
chinois enfin brahim mon cousin et puis
sergio ça un mec de notre quartier
si vous l'avez fait l'album la
cervélo je crois qu'il a achetés sur
internet où on en est très fier de cela
chez jungle parce que même si on est le
plus gros label de rap en france c'est
pas tous les jours qu'on fait diamant
bon bravo les gars pour votre morceau
c'est un carton
merci c'est
clément si on voulait de voir ces
pourparlers de la suite c'est sur ton
morceau avec master qu'on a fait le plus
de stream qu'on a eu les meilleurs
retours et le titre vient d'entrer en
radio
d'accord on va pas passé par quatre
chemins si tu es chaud au clip grave
grave je suis choquée l'ampleur du buzz
on devrait faire ça rapidement ou
nouvelle tournée dans la semaine très
mûr carte c'est parfait en plus j'ai des
idées pour le clip et vous voulez le
tourneo le clip d'un coup de jets
peuvent émerger toi tu es nouveau dans
le game il faut que tu poses ton univers
tac opté grave donc moi j'ai tourné ma
partie de mon côté
et toi tu vois ton état partie de ton
côté comme ça chacun mène sont munis
d'un ok mais ça veut dire que du coup je
serai jamais avec toi l'image ça c'est
pas grave une prochaine fois plus
important la c3 c'est ton image ton
style apache c'est ça qui est important
excusez moi mais n'y connais rien du
tout n'a jamais tourné le clip avant ça
puisqu'il a et flip ton pote quoi mains
c'est bon tu sais rien n'inquiète donc
tu es chaud ouais je suis chaud et le
trash ou
alors tu peux garder tes micro pour toi
comment ça se passe au jeu tranquille je
suis calme souvient la hâte et au câble
ouais d'accord si on pouvait éviter de
crever sur le canapé ça nous arrangerait
bosse là
bon des idées pour le clip pour ta
partie
les gars moi je vous le dit après c'est
mon ami mais ma star ça les arrange bien
ce qui se passe là c'est un baril à des
équipes il a de la tuque où on n'a rien
on l'a jamais fait clip justement on va
leur montrer faut juste qu'on trouve une
idée qui éclate ou non la caf eric
lepine actrice du
val d'ille a déjà fais un
bon faire un clip tous les mecs de la
cité des quads et bestial et d'ailleurs
ça a déjà été fait pas fait qu'après
pour ce samedi un truc
bon la caf eric un animal sauvage suis
pas moi un lion un singe ou puma sept
pays personne ne l'a fait qu'à puma un
puma brille bah ouais je connais
quelqu'un puis matin
non c'est toi qui veulent capturer du
myspace de tebessa non à une fois
réalisateur arrête de dire n'importe
quoi réalisateur réalisateur mathieu
kassovitz
on n'a qu'à demander à cracovie de
schiste en train dans la salle de boxe
jérôme cousin on y vend lui demande
normale c'est quoi ces mesures de parler
même s'il kassovitz qui peut pas on
demande à nos petits bouffons qui fait
des vidéos de skate les natures mortes
aux samoa et la déco pro là des caméras
il a même un drôle riche et auquel on a
des caméras ont filmé quoi avec qui peu
après faut pas tout demander tu avais
moi j'essaye de trouver des solutions de
capter comment je crois que j'ai trouvé
si on y arrive c'est une idée qui
tabasse
faut juste qu'on trouve une bête de
turbo
bon la cre a demandé à la ville qu'elle
n'habite nabé l'automobile frère celui
qui fait du business avec les gars m'ont
seulement ouais ça c'est bon ça c'est
bon trois des comptes est
une dingue greffera
bon par contre les volets de la voiture
là je la garde devant ensuite elle bouge
pas vous mettez devant personne va
conduire les vidéos d'accord quoi il ya
un temps clément là mais t'es sûr de ce
que tu fais hayden est juste bloqué une
autoroute c'est un truc approche mais
justement vient de cela je suis du
sursis ça lui a fait du buzz et même le
procès ça lui a fait du buzz elle
savait que c'est la voiture qui a dans
le clip d'allan dos à
un arbitre sérieusement c'est là qu'est
la voiture qui arrache le plus là la
plus puissante de tout le gard la plus
puissante ouais bah c'est celle là
[Musique]
j'étais 3 500 chevaux neuf mille 500
tours minute 2 0 à 100 en moins de 3
secondes un petit bijou magnifique
ah non non non celle là c'est mort
propriétaire bien la récupérer demain
matin à 10h
faut quand on s'est tenue alors
je gagne quoi moi là dedans
non parce que je suis jugé rond moi ici
vous savez les risques je prends en
sorte un véhicule comme ça sans
l'autorisation du propriétaire
bon écoute mon avis pour logo va le
prendre on met à la fin du clip et totti
fait la pub de l'année déjà ça fait 1 et
secundo clément cayla qui tend vers à
tous les rappeurs qui font blouser mais
tous c'est un bon deal km en plus de 100
à 1000 c'est pas un clip avec n'importe
qui avec ma star
ya massart d'un clip
comment savoir il faut donc quoi servez
avec les petits son show sur leur partie
du clip de quoi sont faits prêter une
porsche gt3 en r&d terre ah ouais
alors alors la star tu connaisses
critique à la chaîne youtube demolition
qui a fait des gros clip pour niño pour
gimp pour lil wayne en tout cas et à
quoi vraiment pas sinon il m'a expliqué
un poteau concept franchement c'est
lourd je voyais direct des groupes les
bacs à la cité d'abraxas ce ménage avec
la weimar l'au-delà déjà fait ça ils
n'ont pas exploité tout le décor mais
passons j'ai une deuxième idée si tu
veux un univers un peu plus serré je
pensais qu'on pouvait tourner à la sq en
pillages et des gars moi là bas
maintenant arrêtez un peu avec ça et ses
aises plenel sur des longs tout s'est
alors ton concept une rame dit des trucs
que tu as fait pour d'autres a peur en
fait mes frères où il a raison
gomorra ça doit l'air du temps tout le
monde qui fait même si la formation qui
s'appelle savastano
justement le mec qui joue savastano ya
quelqu'un qui la ramène dans un clip
personnes ben voila moi je veux ramener
notre jeu
franchement c'est incroyable situe là
mais je crois qu'il est très série et
cinéma je crois que c'est compliqué
ouais non c'est pas compliqué
tout ce que tu vas faire ça embête de
clips donc je me ramener des mugs des
lambeaux ce que tu veux une grue ok
c'est le budget ça passe t'inquiète pas
pour le budget du gc aussi je m'en
occupe balancela prendre alors quand on
va manger une fois sa clique qui
démontre à capter hockey
franchement ma vie des bêtes de caisse
quand même justement en parlant de la
[ __ ] faut prendre moins de l'esquivé sur
vos rouler que la voiture au contrôle un
tri pour l'occuper moi je pense ma bile
vu comment il échoue si tu leur mets une
bête de me fixe des règles bah ouais
c'est une bonne idée ça
fait quoi tu ne manques pas à la meuf la
mine non
les purges fasse pas possible et dans le
jeans axe tu racontes là tu m'as dit f1
course nom de quoi les gars c'est comme
si tu lui demande de jouer
mais c'est pas possible
c'est la seule main gauche qui voulait
tout mon corps j'ai très bien je vais me
marier avec elle et toi tu ramènes
chauffer un gain est obligé brême a
défendu son idée mon prénom
je te plaît c'est important
voici je lui demande mais je vous dis
directeur façon la meuf elle est grave
sérieuse elle est vierge de ouf on va
falloir faire de ce pire parce qu'une
habile il va vite capté qu'il ya moyen
de réduire
nous avions dénoncé
c'est georges tu fais chier témoin le
petit ego la bande de victimes boîte a
fait une tête d'une tête en sol la tête
de ma mère a été soldé voilà bien mais
bon je te parle
ça va redescendre par l'éclat suis lâché
même pas lui chercher au parlement il
sert de l'humanité inclus
comme ça que les choses
non c'est bon tu t'inquiètes songeur
bon écoute moi je t'attendais à faire le
clip et basta d'après attention faut
qu'on prépare ton prochain album dont
l'eau sérieux frère
nathan
j'entraîne gamberger temps il va falloir
tard et de migration terrain tu
t'exposes trop
tes ce qu'on va faire je vais faire
comme si un jour tu vas parler comment
sa re voilà tu sympa
tiens
immostat
dis stop
tammy trop tard hier il n'a pas beaucoup
tiens cette avance
s'est mise à gauche
[Applaudissements]
non étatiques est bien sorti
à
ok
alors ça d'accord c'est bon tout est
carré négation posait comme un adieu au
tour du père est bon hockey
à québec oui c'est bon les jo promo
ouais mais c'est pourtant à ramener
combien 9 khz et qu'est ce que je fais
avec non mais une devant une derrière
deux sur ma gueule une sur le compteur
de vitesse ok bien sûr et après tu iras
avec les gars pour filmer de l'extérieur
attendent les voitures elles restent à
l'arrière était alors antillaises ou
quoi ah non c'est plutôt son erreur qui
a la route 6 après je te présente nina
sallaumines à merci d'être venus mais
franchement c'est koussa wagram nous
aider à bien capter ce que tu dois faire
pareil dit moi juste interactions
imaginer
céline habile ouais grave sombre et
commence à beaucoup de cox q
thomas si je peux prendre effet laissé
par une vache qui soit un compte de
bagasse la gtoi classé action
merci frère dit à kate
voulait faire comment alors on va se
mettre devant la voiture on va tourner
des plans et puis voilà quoi un but je
connais maintenant on s'appelle dont je
connais pas les mineurs c'est qu'elle
est fan de voitures à deux si je n'avais
pas dit non je ne savais pas que la
fatigue aussi ben tu me dis tu me dis
rien toi aussi c'est quoi ton modèle
préféré déjà maintenant
moi mais vous avez préféré plutôt les
les rouges des roses rouges voilà les
rouvre attendait rougement
ouais j'en ai plein trajet que ça j'ai
plein de rouge j'en ai beaucoup de rouge
j'en ai pas mal quoi c'est un moyen de
stimuler le monde s'est tu me fait
kiffer des ouf quand tu veux quoi c'est
vrai ben ouais mais quand mais dès que
possible ballon dire
hey hey tu fais quoi lui est tu fais
quoi toi naveen mais la caméra mais non
non nab et nabil d'habiles nous faut
qu'on commence à tourner donc si tu veux
montrer les voitures à minerve asie et
pendant ce temps on fait un truc au
calme
huawei est ben vas-y fait votre truc
mais dans dix minutes y'a plus rien au
quai dès que je remonte aux quais noirs
mais les gars belga lé pari que
jacqueline nabil abu dhabi les clés se
plaît frère c'est par rapport aux clips
on aura besoin de lumière dans la
voiture la logique n'habite à un clip
sais pas vas-y est c'est quoi si
personne monte dedans personnes rentrent
dans ok c'est bon
ça bouge pas un habile savuth soit
inquiète avec
avec vos gueules la
mrc c'était
commencez avec longueuil ta gueule toi
la
bpm est un peu lent mais je peux
rajouter des drogues elle est bien comme
ça
seconds rôles s'inversent m assad mène
à
[Applaudissements]
si on n'y prend le fonctionnent ces
housses un duo plein jet ou pickup
hockey
charbonnel
décret soit inclure deux ça ça va buzz
efforts tu sais preuve
alors là on est sur un petit bijou à
250000 euros
n'a que deux cents exemplaires
ça peut monter jusqu'à
340 km heure c'est vraiment une petite
merveille
ouais mais tu vois moi ce que j'aime
bien sûr tous cas les rouges
très jeune policier aussi
son confortable les sièges des rouges
moi j'avoue j'aime bien leur joie
j'adore
la vérité des cram
et gravelines
pardon ça soit à chauny ouais là j'ai
chaud d'un tel que c'est souvent les
contrôles et ça ça donne le choix aux
fêtes
en même temps si tu me conte chollat
way
on est fils de [ __ ] au les fils de [ __ ]
[Musique]
et
dans un esprit de bedzin bien voulu
baisser c'est ça
je perds qu'afficher comme un porteur
j'ai déjà lu ni que l'été de roeser j'ai
lâché la concu et les conditions ma
semelle le seul truc qui peut me taper
c'est le sommeil genève tel moins de
lait on dirait que je suis tombé dedans
quand j'étais petit peu mais quand
innovia 7e des produits apple
d'impression phénomène un drame c'est
franchement futur prix nobel ce que tu
veux qu'on se montrer de guerriers le
moment 2 et en double comme un jour
férié jeunes entre 15 et servent à la
prod champêtre dans la matrice
je vais tâcher tellement plonge besson
la patrie ap hm
[Musique]
et voilà c'est pas bien ce que vous avez
fait là bas tu crois que je me suis dit
alors tu peux vraiment je te kiffe
vraiment bon si je te kiffe ouais
mais ils sont quand même en train de
baiser ces bâtards
la
croissance
ce qui m'a baisé killer
et voilà les bâtards tient bien avec moi
tu as tout niké vienne où des vies de
cooldown depuis son arrivée chez soi la
descente peut pas sortir c'est la vie
les actuels détectons sérieux je sais
pas quoi et les fenêtres stresser les
fenêtres la marche pas
ça marche pas le bac or
derrière qui marche
membe c'est jordan faucher un namibien
on ne part pas avec moi
sache que dis je des fosses la ville la
voiture n à rien si tu casses les toits
mais là la voiture elle arrive à hawaï
la raison jusqu'à la bulle quand on
ferait rien la voiture n'a rien du tout
un party partent avec nos doigts et vous
avez de la chance que je l'aide et
bouaké votre copine j'ai pas beaucoup et
armand lattes a déboîté qui votre copine
à celle qui kiffe les voitures rouges
c'est la somme de ma vie 7,9 t on vers
la mer
mais voilà
votre mobile il a dû voter c'est qu'une
nouvelle le dis moi tu es
alors c'est comment
croire
ouais
pourquoi tableau enfin on est très bien
le clip alors ouais bien sûr t'as kiffé
et savastano et toi ça va être
légendaire les gens ne sont pas prêts
pour ça ah ouais bah oui je partie des
petites accusé
la fed d'engager le petit quand même non
c'est la cas parce que tu as préféré là
mais nous la leur
foot ça non si ça buzz pour lui ça buzz
pour tous à gauche toute façon ça reste
mon clip ajoutant dans son enquête
si je peux sortir je sors voir
[Musique]